32 years old alex cobb two starts on the
season there's that 2.89 era love the
strikeout to walk ratio as well eight
punch-outs only three walks jonathan vr
to lead it off for the marlins alex
cobb's first pitch of the game bounced
right back to a little comebacker
one pitch one out out ahead in the count
a ball with two strikes to john bertie
and there it is the off speed down
down down this is that split finger
fastball it starts thigh high as a
hitter you got to commit to go get it
and if you'll watch the action on it
those last four or five feet it is
almost straight down action and the
hitter just can't lay off of it eliezer
hernandez 21 games last season sometime
in the rotation sometime in the bullpen
and won the fifth spot for the 2020
season with a very impressive summer
camp again a long layoff for all the
marlins two on two out
smith in against hernandez
and that's on the outside and called
strike three
it just caught graphically a touch of
the outside corner eliezer strands a
couple of runners here getting dwight
smith looking at strike three
one two
swing and a miss back to the split
change and cobb picks up his second
strikeout so here's cervelli broke the
scoreless tie in the fifth inning last
night
and down goes cervelli on strikes third
strike out of the game for alex cobb two
down
there it is again split finger fastball
so here is a big thrill for eddie
alvarez the miami native the former
speed skater and an olympic medalist and
here's eddie at age 30 a 30 year old
rookie making his major league debut
ground ball to chris davis
step on the bag chance cisco digging in
eliezer has taken care of
cisco cisco goes down on strikes
scoreless in the third two under vr is a
line drive past a shortstop hit out into
left field for the r
so the speed stirs the board with one
out in the third inning now two on and
two out for aguilar bob taking his time
hitters trying to change the pace
runners will get a jump here with the
full cop pitch
here it comes and he got him swinging
laser hernandez senate andrew velazquez
friday lefty match-up balling two
strikes on andrew velasquez they will
check down at third and that is a
strikeout so three strikeouts now for
eliezer hernandez
bounced into the shift he was out five
three his first time and he rips one on
the ground right side this time right at
jesus aguilar who gloves the hot smash
five steps to the bag and that'll do it
for loyalty
1-0 cow to anderson
this is anderson shooting one down the
line off the top of that wall and it's
gonna have just enough to get out for a
home run for brian anderson a
one-nothing marlins lead
oh boy
yes indeed both of brian anderson's home
runs this year going to the opposite
field and what a great game plan we were
just sitting here breaking it down right
if you're a right-handed hitter and
you're going up against alex cobb you
know you're seeing it all now this is a
fastball that splits the plate paul
remember when i was telling you early in
the count if you see this pitch you're
probably gonna get a better swing at it
with two strikes you might not because
you're dealing with a splitty and a
curveball that joyce has seen a thing or
two in his long career been in pro ball
since 2005.
cop fools him there
goes down swinging
eliezer hernandez hernandez has yet to
allow a hit he's hit about her walk to
man but he's retired last seven straight
iglesias out to left and dickerson makes
the play one down in the fourth one to
nunez a swing and a missed elevated
fastball and eliezer hernandez has the
strikeout his fourth in the game so a
two hour chance for austin hayes the
center fielder
first ball hitting hayes skies went out
into right center field moving over
monte harrison makes the call makes the
catch and that's all for the o's in the
fourth
marlins have brian anderson in shallow
right
and a foul tip into the mitt for
strikeout number five for eliezer
hernandez one away francisco struck out
and he's only at that
hit pretty well down the left field line
and that is a fair ball
and it hops into the stand so two bases
for chance cisco and the orioles have a
one out double here in the fifth and
we're gonna have a pinch hitter as you
take a look at chance cisco out at
second base that's the tying run
pedro severino
off the bench and he will hit for andrew
velasquez looper into center this could
fall
it's in and cisco had to wait and make
sure so he advances to third and the
orioles have runners on the corner
and the marlins will go to their bullpen
the orioles are threatening for the
first time today they've got chance
cisco at third base they've got pedro
severino first one out and nick vincent
is on to make his marlins debut big
right hand in the face hansen alberto
the top of the order for the orioles and
there's a ground ball up the middle it's
gonna be a double play ball nick vincent
on the first pitch he throws as a member
of the marlins induces the double play
to keep this game right where it is
essentially the bottom of the ninth
inning and that's why don mattingly has
turned to his closer brandon kinsler who
pitched last night it was not a save
situation but finished off a marlins
shutout win he's trying to do the same
thing today
on the outside edge for a called strike
three one away and career strikeout
number 300 for brandon kinsler
so one out in the inning sends up chris
davis
this one to third brian anderson goes
across his body and aguilar able to keep
his toe on the bag two away
what a play by brian anderson is it done
young man
to the backhand with the shift on and
then you see the strong arm and aguilar
holding the back let's not forget this
is a one-nothing ball game and well he's
got a home run in this game tying run on
base pedro's severino will now step in
three balls two strikes two outs
runner goes pitches
for a call strike three
it's a marlins win